y en nuestra sección de salud nos
acompaña como todas las mañanas más
Romero sala mar bienvenida Buenos días
bienvenida tú también María Clara hoy
vamos a hablar del que ha sido el tema
de la semana y son las contaminaciones
en el aire que se han vivido en Canadá y
en distintas ciudades de Estados Unidos
por los incendios forestales en Canadá y
simplemente comenzar con un dato Aunque
ayer Nueva York registró la peor calidad
de aire de todo el mundo hoy los niveles
de contaminación han bajado y se
encuentran incluso por debajo de otros
lugares como Filadelfia comienzo
Entonces por preguntar Cuáles son las
consecuencias de este humo en la salud
sí son imágenes de claramente que
parecen ciencia ficción no veíamos esos
cielos naranjas esas llamas también
totalmente abrasadoras en en Canadá
gracias a estos vientos que están
moviendo todo el humo en la dirección de
la costa pues noreste de Estados Unidos
y como decías Nueva York quizás fue la
que más espacio acumuló pero no es la
única ciudad también en el mismo país de
Canadá donde están sucediendo de hecho
los incendios donde han sonado todas
estas alertas por la mala calidad del
aire pero precisamente comentábamos no
que para comprender mejor el impacto de
esta situación queríamos comprender qué
es lo que es lo que consideramos mala
calidad del aire no qué es lo que
provoca mala calidad del aire y qué es
lo que lo impacta Entonces vamos a
empezar por ahí mejor la que las que nos
deben preocupar más lo que nos debe
preocupar más en el caso de las malas
calidades de la serie del aire en los
incendios son especialmente las
partículas la materia en partículas
diminutas estamos hablando de lo que se
conoce como
pm2,5 pm 10 no que eso significan Pues
el diámetro que tienen estas partículas
y que son de hecho menores más pequeñas
que el grueso por ejemplo de un cabello
no Entonces esto es una de las cosas que
contaminan y que consideramos mala
calidad del aire cuando los niveles de
partículas son altas Pero también
hablamos cuando hablamos de maleada del
aire del ozono o de lo que conocemos
como Smoke del ozono a nivel
del suelo no no el que está en la
atmósfera sino el que está a nivel del
suelo sucede cuando se combina la luz
solar con lo que se llaman
óxidos de nitrógeno que son gases que se
emiten de las fábricas de los coches Y
de lo que también se llama compuestos
orgánicos volátiles que son gases que se
emiten pues por ejemplo por pinturas o
por disolventes todo esto muy presente
en ciudades o en zonas industriales todo
eso combinado provoca este esto que
conocemos como que cubre tantas ciudades
que conocemos hoy en día pero es verdad
que cuando hablamos particularmente de
los incendios el protagonista aquí es de
esta materia particulada el Smoke no
juega tanto pero pues queríamos
aprovechar la oportunidad para recordar
que todo esto es lo que consideramos
mala calidad del aire Bueno entonces
concentrémonos en esta materia
particular cuáles son sus impactos en
los humanos cuando los respiramos sí En
el caso de las partículas son tan
pequeñas como decías no que que sin
darnos cuenta Bueno aunque probablemente
en estas ciudades sí se estén dando
cuenta en este momento pero en muchas
veces ni siquiera sabemos que están ahí
y pueden depositarse pueden acumularse
en nuestro sistema respiratorio
particularmente las de 2,5 que llegan
más profundamente porque precisamente
son más pequeñas mientras que las de PM
10 suelen impactar y acumularse digamos
en las vías respiratorias altas esto
puede provocar dañar el tejido pulmonar
inflamarlo no una exposición a corto
plazo puede ser dañina por ejemplo en
términos de provocar inflamaciones como
bronquitis ataques de asma por ejemplo
pero es cierto que no suele dejar
efectos a largo plazo a no ser que sea
un grupo de riesgo como personas con
enfermedades previas niños pequeños
personas adultas mayores pero la
exposición a largo plazo Es
particularmente peligrosa no provoca
todo tipo de enfermedades respiratorias
cardiovasculares un estudio publicado en
2021 por delante cua de hecho el impacto
de la polución por por los incendios
particularmente sabemos que la polución
del aire provoca unos siete millones de
Muertos anuales pero particularmente de
los incendios son más de 33.000 Muertos
anuales como decíamos sobre todo por
enfermedades de corazón o de zonas
respiratorias y de hecho las zonas con
más mortalidad aunque no son las más
contaminadas son Sudamérica y Asia
central por ejemplo Perú México Así que
también pues nos invitan estos datos a
mirar que está sucediendo en nuestra
propia región y precisamente no solo
ante estos datos sino ante el humo
totalmente contaminado y el aire
contaminado en lugares como Canadá están
haciendo todo lo que pueden para evitar
que ingrese a las casas Cuáles son las
recomendaciones que nos dan los
científicos al respecto si vamos hay
varias recomendaciones no que sirven
ahora para las personas que están
sufriendo esto pero que todos deberíamos
tener presentes porque probablemente
estos incendios van a suceder en más
lugares del mundo y con más frecuencia a
raíz del cambio climático la primera
como decíamos quedarse
casa limitar el tiempo afuera quedarnos
en espacios interiores también evitar
actividades de esfuerzo físico que nos
hacen inhalar más no con más rapidez
Esto no se recomienda para nada en estos
momentos de crisis más alta de mala
calidad del aire dentro de las casas
tratar de mantener limpio el aire
interior bloquear bien puertas ventanas
si hay sistemas de aire acondicionado
evitar que cojan aire desde el exterior
no Y también evitar cosas como que
contaminen adentro Como por ejemplo
cocinar cosas que puedan ser muy
grasosas o emitir mucho aire o barrer
mucho no se recomienda en estos momentos
tratar de dejar el aire lo más quieto
posible por supuesto si salimos usar
mascarillas nuestras conocidas
mascarillas en el 95 por ejemplo no en
este caso son unas de las que más ayudan
y pues al final también conocer nuestras
propias condiciones de salud y nuestro
propio riesgo saber que si somos
personas que ya tenemos problemas
respiratorios o cardiovasculares tratar
de cuidarnos lo máximo posible sin para
terminar no vemos que estas
recomendaciones son especialmente
difíciles para algunas personas
especialmente para de pronto las clases
más trabajadoras No qué trabajos
permiten el teletrabajo no son todos los
trabajos No qué trabajos son de esfuerzo
físico Cuáles no Quiénes se pueden
permitir no hacer este esfuerzo físico
que pueda requerir algún trabajo Estos
son preguntas que nos deberíamos hacer
también qué casas Están adaptadas con
aire acondicionado con filtros de aire
para poder permitirse realmente tener
cerrado todo y aislado y que dentro sea
igual un mente un espacio habitable y
por supuesto Qué grupos de gente tienen
más prevalencia de estas enfermedades
cardiovasculares o de estas enfermedades
respiratorias que como suelen ser clases
más empobrecidas también entonces en
este sentido recordar que estos impactos
no afectan de la misma forma a todo al
mundo y que ahora nos centramos en Nueva
York pero que hay ciudades como Nueva
Delhi que viven así Estos son imágenes
por ejemplo que estábamos viendo de la
India que viven así en su día
a día por lo tanto con estas
exposiciones a largo plazo tan
peligrosas como comentábamos Justo eso
le iba a decir que si bien Ahora la
noticia está concentrada en Estados
Unidos todo el año durante todo el
tiempo ciudades como usted menciona
viven unas condiciones críticas de
contaminación mar gracias por este
amplio reporte de salud Gracias María